president of the united states
hello folks
thanks for being here
well good afternoon everyone
tomorrow will mark uh
one year since i took office
it's been a year of challenges but it's
also been a year of enormous progress we
went from 2 million people being
vaccinated at the moment i was sworn in
to 210 million americans being fully
vaccinated today
we created 6 million new jobs
more jobs in one year than any time
before
unemployment dropped the unemployment
rate dropped to 3.9 percent
child poverty dropped by nearly 40
percent the biggest drop ever in
american history
new business applications grew by 30
the biggest increase ever
and for the first time in a long time
this country's working people actually
got a raise
actually got a raise people before the
bottom 40
saw their income go up
the most of all the cataracts
we cut health insurance premiums for
millions of american families and we
just made surprise medical bills illegal
in this country
you know those bills you get that you
don't expect after two to five thousand
dollars from the hospital beyond what
you thought you were going to have to
owe because the consultation you weren't
told was going to cost that much
no more
they're now illegal
thanks to the american rescue plan and
other actions we've taken
we've seen record job creation record
economic growth in the past year
now
thanks to the bipartisan infrastructure
bill we're about to make a record
investment in rebuilding america to take
us to be the number one
what best infrastructure in the world
well now we're way below that
we'll be creating better jobs for
millions of people modernizing our roads
our bridges our highways our ports our
airports
everything from
making clean water let removing lead
pipes
that every american turnout every
american can turn on a faucet and drink
clean water
urban and rural and suburban communities
it's going to make affordable high-speed
internet available to every american in
urban rural and suburban areas
we've never done that before
now we are we're in the process of
getting that done
still for all this progress i know
there's a lot of frustration
and fatigue in this country
and we know why
proven 19
omicron has has now been challenging us
in a way that
it's the new enemy
but while it's caused
for concern
it's not cause for panic
we've been doing everything we can
learning and adapting as fast as we can
and preparing for a future beyond the
pandemic
all i know that after almost two years
of physical emotional and psychological
weight of this pandemic and had the
impact it's had on everyone for many of
us
it's been too much to bear
we're in a very different place now
though
we have the tools
vaccines boosters
masks test pills to save lives and keep
businesses and schools open
75 percent of adults are fully
vaccinated
we've gone from 90 million adults with
no shots in arms last summer and down to
35 million with no shots as of today
and we're adding about 9 million more
vaccinations each week
we're going to stick with our
vaccination efforts because vaccinations
work
so get vaccinated please
and get your booster
look
we're also increasing testing
should we have done more testing earlier
yes
but we're doing more now we've gone from
zero at home test a year ago to 375
million tests on the market in just this
month if you buy a test of the store
your insurance will reimburse you
on top of that
we're making one billion one billion at
home tests available for you to order
and be delivered to your home for free
just visit covettest.gov
to know how to get that free
test kit to your home in addition there
are 20 000 sites where you can get
tested in person for free
now and now
we have more treatments that people can
that for people who keep people out of
the hospital than any other point in the
pandemic including life-saving antiviral
pills
we purchased 20 million of these new
pfizer pills
more than any country in the world
and the bottom line on cover 19
is that we're in a better place than
we've been and have been thus far
clearly better than a year ago
we're not going to back
we're not going back to lockdowns we're
not going back to closing schools
schools should stay open
because the american rescue plan
we provided the states 130 billion
dollars 130 billion dollars to keep our
students and educators safe and schools
open
funding for ventilation systems in
schools social distancing hygiene for
classrooms and school buses
in addition we've added another 10
billion dollars for covet 19 tests to be
able to be ministers administered at
schools
and many states and school districts
have spent this money very well
unfortunately some haven't
i encourage the states and school
districts that use the funding to
protect our children and keep our
schools open use it
the covet 19 is not going to give up and
accept things uh you know it's just it's
not going to go away
immediately but i'm not going to give up
and accept things as they are now
some people may call what's happening
now the new normal
i call it a job not yet finished
it will get better
or moving toward a time when covet 19
won't disrupt our daily lives
but covet 19 won't be a crisis
but something to protect against and a
threat
look
we're not there yet but we will get
there
now the second challenge we're facing
are prices
covet 19 has created a lot of economic
complications
including
rapid price increases across the world
economy
people see it at the gas pumps the
grocery stores and elsewhere
so here's what we're going to do
a critical job in making sure that the
elevated prices don't become entrenched
rests with the federal reserve which has
a dual mandate
full employment and stable prices
the federal reserve provided
extraordinary support during the crisis
for the previous year and a half
given the strength of our economy
and the pace of recent price increases
it's appropriate as the federal chairman
chairman powell the fed chairman powell
has indicated to recalibrate the support
that is now necessary
i respect the fred the fed's
independence and i've nominated five
superb individuals to serve on the
federal board of governors
men and women
from a variety of ideological
perspectives
they're eminently qualified
historically diverse and have heard
bipartisan praise
i call the united states senate to
confirm them without any further delay
and here at the white house
and for my friends in congress the best
thing to tackle high prices is a more
productive economy
with greater capacity to deliver goods
and services to the american people
and a growing economy where folks have
more choices
and more small businesses compete and
where more goods can get to market
faster and cheaper
i've laid out a three-part plan to do
just that
first
fix the supply chain
covet 19 has had a global impact on the
economy
when a factory shuts down in one part of
the world shipments to shops and homes
and businesses all over the world are
disrupted
covet 19 has compounded that many times
over
a couple of months ago
in this very room we talked we heard
dire warnings
about how the supply chain problems
could create a real crisis around the
holidays
so we acted
we brought together business and labor
and that much predicted crisis did not
occur
99 of the packages were delivered on
time
and shelves were stocked
and notwithstanding the recent storms
that have impacted many parts of our
country
the share of goods
in stock at stores is 89
now
which is barely changed from the 91
before the pandemic
i often see empty shells being shown on
television
89 percent are full
which is only a few points below what it
was before the pandemic
but our work's not done
my infrastructure law
will supercharge your effort upgrading
everything from roads and bridges
to ports and airports
railways and transit to make the economy
move faster and reduce prices for
families
second thing
my build back better plan will address
the biggest cost of working families
face every day
no other plan will do more to lower the
cost for american families
it cuts the cost of for child care
many families including the people
sitting in this room if they have
children and they're working full time
many families pay up to 14 000 a year
for child care in big cities less than
that and smaller ones
my plan cuts that in half
that will not only be a game changer for
so many families budgets but it will
mean so much
for nearly two million women
women who've left the workforce during
the pandemic because of things like
child care
my build back better plan cuts the price
of prescription drugs so insulin
that today costs some people as much as
a thousand dollars a month
will cost no more than 35 a month
it cuts the cost of elder care it lowers
energy to cost and it will do all this
without raising a single penny in taxes
on people making under 400 dollars a
year or
raising the deficit
in fact my plan cuts the deficit
and it boosts the economy by getting
more people into the workforce
that's why 17 nobel prize winners for
economics say will ease long-term
inflationary pressure
the bottom line
if price increases are what you're
worried about
the best answer is my build-back better
plan
third thing we're going to do promote
competition
look in too many industries
a handful of giant companies dominate
the market in sectors like meat
processing railroad shipping and other
areas
this isn't a new issue it's not been the
reason we've had high inflation today
it's not the only reason
it's been happening for a decade
but over time it has reduced competition
squeezed out small businesses and
farmers ranchers and increase the price
for consumers
we end up with an industry like the meat
processing industry
where four big companies dominate the
markets
pay ranchers less for their cattle they
grow
charge consumers more for beef hamburger
meat whatever they're buying prices are
up
look
i'm a capitalist
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism it's exploitation
so i signed an executive order to tackle
unfair competition on our economy we're
going to continue to enforce it
along with working with congress where
we can
a close of this
we have faced some of the biggest
challenges that we've ever faced in this
country
these past few years
challenges to our public health
challenges to our economy
but we're getting through it
and not only are we getting through it
we're laying the foundation for future
where america wins the 21st century
by creating jobs at a record pace
now we need to get inflation under
control
we have developed an extraordinarily
effective booster shots and anti-viral
pills now we need to finish the job to
get covet 19 under control
i've long said
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people or america
i believe that more than ever today
we've seen the grit determination in the
american people this past year
but the best days of this country are
still ahead of us not behind us
i'm happy to take questions
yes
thank you mr president i know some of my
colleagues will get into some specific
issues but i wanted to zoom out on your
first year in office
inflation is up
your signature domestic legislation is
stalled in congress
in a few hours from now the senate an
effort in the senate to deal with voting
rights and voting
voting reform legislation is going to
fail
kova 19 is still taking the lives of
1500 americans every day
and the nation's divisions are just as
raw as they were a year ago did you over
promise to the american public what you
could achieve in your first year in
office and how do you plan to course
correct going forward why are you such
an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
the fact of the matter is that uh
we're in a situation where
we have made enormous progress you
mentioned the number of deaths from
covet well it was
three times that not long ago
it's coming down everything's changing
it's getting better
look
i didn't over promise
but
i think if you take a look at what we've
been able to do
you'd have to acknowledge we made
enormous progress
but one of the things that i think
is something that
one thing i haven't been able to do so
far
is get my republican friends to get in
the game of making things better in this
country for example i was reading the
other day and i wrote the quote down so
i don't misquote him
a quote from senator sununu
when he decided that he wasn't going
excuse me governor sununu when he
decided he wasn't going to run for the
senate in new hampshire here's what he
said
they were all for the most quote they
were all for the most part content with
the speed at which they weren't doing
anything
it was very clear that we just had to
hold the line for two years
okay
so i'm just going to
be a roadblock for the next two years
that's not what i do sununu said
he went on to say it bothered me
that they were okay with that
then he goes on to say i said okay so
we're not going to get stuff done
if we win the white house back
if we win the white house back
why didn't we do anything in 2017 and
2018
and then he said how the republican
sununu spoke to answer the challenge he
said crickets yeah crickets
they had no answer
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a
stalwart effort to make sure
that the most important thing was that
president biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for
and so
the problem here is that i think what's
happens what i have to do
and the and the change in and tactic if
you will
i have to make clear to the american
people
what we are for we've passed alive
we passed a lot of things that people
don't even understand what's all that's
in it understandably
remember when we passed the affordable
care act
and everybody thought that you know it
really was getting pummeled and beaten
and it wasn't until after out of office
and that next campaign when uh that
off-year campaign
and i went into a hope i wasn't in
office anymore in a whole bunch of
districts campaigning for democrats and
republican districts who said they
wanted to do away with with
health care with obamacare
and i started pointing out that if you
did that pre-existing conditions would
no longer be covered
and they said huh
we didn't know that
we didn't know that and guess what
we won over 38 seats
because we explained to the people
exactly what
in fact had passed
now one of the things that i remember
saying and i'll end this i remember
saying to
president obama when he passed the
affordable care act i said you ought to
take a victory lap
and he said there's so many things going
on we don't have time to take a victory
lap
as a consequence no one knew what the
detail of the legislation was
they don't know a lot of the detail of
what we passed so the difference is
i'm going to be out on the road a lot
making the case around the country
with my colleagues who are up for
re-election and others making the case
of what we did do
and what we want to do
what we need to do
and so i don't think i've over promised
at all and i'm gonna stay on this track
you know one of the things that uh i
remember and i'll end this
i was talking with uh you know uh
jim clyburn
who was a great help to me in the
campaign in south carolina
and jim said and when he endorsed me and
there was a there was a clip on
television
last couple days
of jim
and it said that we want to make things
accessible and affordable
for all americans
that's healthcare
that's education
that's
prescription drugs
that's making sure you have access
access to all the things that everybody
else has we can afford to do that we can
we can't afford not to do it
so i tell my republican friends here i
come
this is going to be about what are you
for
what are you for
and lay out what we're for
um uh
mary bruce abc
thank you mr president
you mentioned your republican colleagues
but right now your top two legislative
priorities your social spending package
and voting rights legislation are
stalled blocked by your own party after
months of negotiation you are only
guaranteed control of washington for one
more year before the midterms do you
need to be more realistic and scale down
these priorities in order to get
something passed
no
i don't think so when you say more
realistic i think it's extremely
realistic to say to people
because let me back up
you all really know
the politics of this country and your
networks and others you spend a lot of
time which i'm glad you do
pulling this data determining where they
are what the american people's attitudes
are etc
american people overwhelming
agree with me on prescription drugs they
overwhelmingly agree with me on the cost
of education they overwhelmingly agree
with me on early education they
overwhelm and go on the list on on on
child care
and so
we just have to make the case what we're
for and what the other team's not for
look
we knew all along that a lot of this was
going to be an uphill fight
and one of the ways to do this is to
make sure we make the contrast as clear
as we can
and one of the things that i think is
we're going to have to do
is just make the case i don't think
there's anything unrealistic about what
we're asking i'm not trying to i'm not
asking for castles in the sky
i'm asking for practical things the
american people have been asking for for
a long time
a long time
and i think we can get it done
you're not going to scale down any of
these priorities but so far that
strategy isn't working you haven't been
able to get some of these big
legislative ticket items done real big
ones done bigger than any president has
ever gotten in the first year but
currently mr president
your spending package voting rights
legislation they're not going anywhere
so that's true is there anything that
you are confident you can get signed
into law before the midterm elections
yes i'm confident we can get uh
pieces big chunks of the bill back
better law signed in law and i'm
confident that we can take the case to
the american people that the people they
should be voting for who are going to
oversee whether elections in fact are
legit or not should not be those who are
being put up by the republicans to
deduct to determine that they're going
to be able to change the outcome of the
election so whether or not we can
actually get an election and by the way
i haven't given up we haven't finished
the vote yet on what's going on on on
the
um on voting rights and the john lewis
bill and others but uh
um so
look this is
i i've been engaged a long time in
public policy
and i don't know many things that have
been done
in
one fell swoop
and so i think the bet the most
important thing to do
is try to
inform not educate inform the public
of what's at stake
in stark terms and let them make
judgments and let them know who's for
them and who's to get them who's there
and who's not there and make that the
case and that's what i'm going to be
spending my time doing in this off-year
election
you mentioned republicans in reaching
out to them some republicans who may be
open to major changes on voting rights
for instance like mitt romney he says he
never even received a phone call from
this white house why not i like
look mitt romney's a straight guy he's
uh and
one of the things that we're doing i was
trying to make sure we got everybody on
the same page in my party on this score
and i didn't call many republicans uh at
all the fact is that um
i i do think that mitt is a serious guy
i think we can get things done i think i
predict you to get something done on the
electoral reform side of this
but um
rather than judge what's going to get
done and not get done
all i can say is i'm going to continue
to make the case why it's so important
to not turn the electoral process over
to political persons who are set up
deliberately to change the outcome of
elections
[Music]
allison harris
thank you mr president speaking of
voting rights legislation if this isn't
passed do you still believe the upcoming
election will be fairly conducted and
its results will be legitimate
well it all depends on uh
whether or not we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
and it's one thing look
maybe i'm just
being uh
too much of an optimist
remember how we thought not that many
people were going to show up to vote in
the middle of a pandemic
we had the highest voter turnout in the
history of the united states of america
well um i think if in fact no matter how
hard they make it for minorities to vote
i think you're going to see them willing
to stand in line
and and defy the attempt to keep them
from being able to vote i think you're
going to see the people we're trying to
keep from being able to show up showing
up and making the sacrifice that needs
to be made in order to change the law
back to what it should be
and
but it's going to be difficult i i make
no bones about that it's going to be
difficult but we're not there yet we've
not run out of options yet and we'll see
how this moves and on omicron and
education teachers are in result in some
revolt in so many places parents are at
odds over closing schools and remote
learning you say we're not going to go
back to closing schools you said that
just moments ago
yet they're closing in some areas what
do you say to those teachers and
principals and parents about school
closings and what can your
administration do to help make up for
learning loss for students first of all
i put in perspective the question you
asked
very few schools are closing
over 95
are still open so you all phrase the
questions when people i don't think it's
deliberate on your part but your phrase
the question of anyone watching this on
television my god there must be all
those schools must be closing what are
we going to do
95
are still open number one
number two
the idea
that parents don't think it's important
for their children to be in school
and teachers know it as well that's why
we made sure that we had the ability to
provide the funding
through the recovery act through the act
that we the the first act we passed
to be able to make sure schools were
able to be
safe
so we have new ventilation systems
available for them we have the way they
handle they scrub down the laboratories
and
i mean the laboratories kids go to to go
to the bathroom
uh cafeterias buses etc
that all that money's there there's
billions of dollars made available
that's there
not every school district has used it as
well as it should be used but
it's there
and so in addition to that there is now
another 10 billion dollars for testing
of students in the schools so i i think
as time goes on
it's much more likely you're going to
see that number go back up from 95 back
up to 98 99
but the the outfit
the individuals of the district that
says we're not going to be open is
always going to get and i'm not being
critical of any of you it's always going
to get front page
it's always going to be the top of the
news but let's put it in perspective
95 as high as 98 percent of the schools
in america are open
functioning
and capable of doing the job
um
uh how about uh uh
jan epstein bloomberg
mr president thank you
um
your top foreign policy advisors have
warned that russia is now ready to
attack ukraine but there's still little
unity among european allies about what a
package of sanctions against moscow
would look like
if the us and nato aren't willing to put
troops on the line to defend ukraine
american allies can't agree on a
sanctions package hasn't the u.s and the
west lost nearly all of its leverage
over vladimir putin and uh given how
ineffective sanctions have been in
deterring putin in the past why should
the threat of new sanctions give him
pause
well because he's never seen
sanctions like the ones i promised will
be imposed if he moves number one
number two we're in a situation where
uh vladimir putin is about to uh we've
had very frank discussions uh vladimir
putin and i
and
[Music]
the idea that nato is not going to be
united i don't buy i've spoken to every
major nato leader
we've had the nato russian summit we've
had other the osce has met etc and so i
think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having a
fight about what to do and not do
etcetera but if they actually do what
they're capable of doing with the force
of mass on the border it is going to be
a disaster for russia if they further
engrade you
invade ukraine and that our allies and
partners are ready to impose severe cost
and significant harm on russia and the
russian economy
and you know we're going to fortify our
nato allies i told them on the eastern
flank if in fact he does invade
we're going to i've already shipped over
600 million dollars worth of
sophisticated equipment defensive
equipment to the ukrainians the cost of
going into ukraine in terms of physical
loss of life for the russians and
they'll they'll be able to prevail over
time but it's going to be heavy it's
going to be real it's going to be
consequential in addition to that putin
has a you know has a stark choice uh he
either de-escalation or diplomacy uh
confrontation of the consequences look i
think you're going to see
for example
everybody talks about how russia has
control over the uh the energy supply
that europe absorbs
well guess what that
that that money that they earn from that
makes about 45 of the economy
i don't see that as a one-way street
they go ahead and cut it off
it's like my mother used to say you're
biting your nose off to spite your face
it's not like they have all these
wonderful choices out there
i spoke with the prime minister of
finland
uh you know we're talking about uh uh
concern on the part of finland and
sweden about what russia is doing the
last thing that that russia needs is
finland deciding to change its status
they didn't say they're gonna do that
but they're talking about what in fact
is going on and how outrageous russia
has been
we're finding ourselves in a position
where i believe you'll see that there'll
be severe economic consequences for
example anything that involves dollar
denominations if they make a if they
invade they're going to pay they're not
going their banks will not be able to
deal in dollars
so there's a lot going to happen but
here's the thing
my conversation with putin and we've
been um
how can we say it
we have no
problem understanding one another
he has no problem understanding me nor
me him
and the
direct the conversations were i pointed
out i said you know
you've occupied before
other countries
but the price has been extremely high
how long
you can go in and over time at great
loss and economic loss go in and occupy
ukraine
but
how many years
one three five ten
what what is that going to take what
toll does that take
it's real it's consequential
so this is not all just a cake walk
for russia
militarily they have overwhelming
superiority
and on
as it relates to ukraine
but they'll pay a stiff price
immediately
near term medium term and long term if
they do it
um i'm sorry
okay
um uh
david sanger new york times
thank you mr president i wanted to
follow up on your answer there uh about
russia and ukraine
when you were in geneva in june
you said to us
about president putin i think the last
thing he wants now is a cold war
now since then of course you've seen him
gather these troops hundred thousand
troops around ukraine your secretary of
state said today he thought he could
invade it at any moment you've seen the
cyber attacks
and you've seen the demand that he have
a sphere of influence in which you would
withdraw
all american troops and nuclear weapons
from what used to be the soviet bloc so
i'm wondering if you still think
that the last thing he wants is a cold
war
and has your view of him changed in the
past few months
and if it has
and he does invade would your posture be
to really move back
to the kind of containment policy that
you saw so often when you were
still in the senate
the answer is that um
i think he still does not want any
full-blown war
number one
number two
do i think he'll test
the west test the united states and nato
as
as
significantly as he can yes i think he
will
but i think he'll pay a serious and dear
price for it that he doesn't think now
will cost him what it's going to cost
him
and i think he'll regret having done it
now
whether or not i think that
how can i say this
in a public forum
i think
that
he
is dealing with
what i believe he thinks is the most
tragic thing that's happened
to mother russia
in that
the berlin wall came down the empire has
been lost and near abroad is gone etc
the soviet union has been
split
but think about what he has
he has eight time zones
a burning tundra that will not freeze
again
naturally
a situation where he has a lot of oil
and gas
but he is trying to find his place in
the world between
china and the west
and so i'm not so sure
that
he has
uh
david i'm not so sure he has uh
is certain what he's going to do my
guess is he will move in
he has to do something and by the way
i've indicated him
the two things he said to me that he
wants guarantees on
one is
ukraine will never be part of nato
and two
that
nato or the there will not be strategic
weapons stationed in
ukraine
well we can work out something on the
second piece
pretending what he does along the
russian line as well the russian border
in the european area of russia
on the first piece
we have a number of treaties
internationally and in europe that
suggests that you get to choose who you
want to be with
but the likelihood that ukraine is going
to join nato in the near term is not
very likely
based on
much more work they have to do in terms
of democracy and a few other things
going on there
and whether or not the major allies in
the west would vote to bring ukraine in
right now
so there's room to work if he wants to
do that but i think as usual he's going
to
i probably shouldn't go any further but
i think it will hurt him badly
it sounds like you're
offering
some way out here some off-ramp and it
sounds like what it is is
at least an informal assurance
that nato is not going to
take in ukraine
any time in the next few decades and it
sounds like you're saying we would never
put nuclear weapons there he also wants
us to move all of our nuclear weapons
out of europe and not have
troops rotating through the old soviet
block do you think there's space for the
there no
no there's not space for that we won't
permanently station but the idea we're
not going to we're going to actually
increase true presence in poland or
romania et cetera if in fact he moves
because we have a sacred obligation in
article 5 to defend those countries they
are part of nato we don't have that
obligation relative to ukraine although
we have great concern about what happens
in ukraine
thank you
um
maureen
usa today
thank you mr president i want to follow
up on your comment on uh build back
better and also ask you a question about
the pandemic you said that you're
confident you can pass big chunks of
buildback better this year does that
wording mean that you are thinking about
you're looking at breaking the package
up into
individual portions
and then on the pandemic now that the
supreme court has blocked the
vaccination or test rule for larger
businesses are you can reconsidering
whether to require vaccines for domestic
flights as a way to boost vaccination
rates
uh no look
first of all
on the
last part of the question
the supreme court decision i think was a
mistake but you still see
thousands and thousands of people who
work for major corporations having to be
tested as a consequence of the decision
made by the corporation not by the
standard i said that that is there
i think you'll see that increase not
decrease number one
what was the first part of your question
uh on your your comment that you made
that you're confident that major chunks
of build better can pass are you
breaking it up yes well
it's clear to me that
um that we're going to have to
probably uh break it up
i think that we can get and i've been
talking to
a number of my colleagues on the hill i
think it's clear that
we would be able to get support for
the
four of the 500 plus billion dollars for
uh energy and the environmental issues
that are there
on number one
number two
i know that
the two people who've opposed on the
democratic side at least
support a number of things that are in
there for example joe manchin strongly
supports early education three year and
four years of age strongly supports that
um there is strong support for
i think
a number of
the way in which to pay for these
uh
pay for this proposal
so i think there is i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna negotiate against myself as to
what should and shouldn't be in it but i
think we can
break the package up get as much as we
can now and come back and fight for the
rest later
um
ken wall street journal ken thomas
thank you mr president i wanted to ask
you about the economy as you said
earlier americans are feeling the
squeeze of inflation uh oil prices have
been at about a seven year high recently
how long should americans expect to face
higher prices when they're at the
grocery store when they're at the gas
pump is this something that they're
going to see
into the summer into next fall
or and and separately you know you talk
about the importance of the fed but
isn't that an acknowledgement that
you're limited in what you can do if you
if if you're relying on the fed to make
decisions and you're unable to get a
build back better proposal through
aren't you simply limited in what you
can do to deal with inflation
well look uh as you know ken
the inflation has everything to do with
the supply chain
and
i think what you're seeing is that
we've been able to make
progress on speeding up
the access to
materials
for for example
one third
of the call of the
increase in cost of living is the cost
of automobiles
the reason automobiles have skyrocketed
in price is because of lack of computer
chips
so we have the capacity and we're going
to do everything in our power to do it
to become self-reliant on the computer
chips that we need
in order to be able to produce more
automobiles
that's underway we've already passed
within the context of another bill
money for that in the uh in the house of
representatives before the house
representatives now but i think there's
a way we can move to
if we can move to get for example that
one thing done
it can make a big difference in terms of
the cost of the total cost of
living now with regard to
um
the whole issue of energy prices
um
that gets a little more complicated but
you saw what happened when i was able to
convince everyone from including china
india a number of other countries to
agree with us to go into their version
of the of this of their petroleum
reserve to release more into the market
so that that brought down the price
about 12 15 cents a gallon some places
some places more
there's going to be a there's going to
be a reckoning along the line here as to
whether or not we're going to continue
to see oil prices continue to go up
in ways that are going up now relative
to what is going to what impact that's
going to have on the producers
and so
um it's going to be hard i think that's
the place where most middle class people
work class people get hit the most they
pull up to a pump and all of a sudden
instead of paying
two dollars and forty cents a gallon
they're paying five dollars a gallon
that's going to be really difficult but
so we're going to continue to work on
trying to increase oil supplies that are
available and i think there's ways in
which we can be of some value added in
terms of the price of gas natural gas
and the like to take the burden off the
european countries that
are now totally dependent on on russia
but it's going to be hard it's going to
be very hard but i think that we have to
deal with for example like i said you
have a circumstance where
people are paying more for a pound of
hamburger meat than they ever paid well
one of the reasons for that is you don't
have that many folks out there that are
the ones that are got the big four
controlling it all
and so you're going to see more and more
we're going to move on this competition
piece to allow more and more smaller
operations to come in and be able to
engage in providing buying and providing
the access to much cheaper
meat
than
than exists now but it's going to be a
haul now and as you i assume the reason
you said if i can't get bill back better
it relates to
what those
17 nobel laureate economists said that
if in fact we could pass it it would
actually lower the impact on inflation
reduce inflation over time etc
so there's a lot we have to do
it's not going to be easy but i think we
can get it done but it's going to be
painful for a lot of people in the
meantime that's why the single best way
the single best way to take the burden
off middle class and work class folks is
to pass the buildback better piece that
are things that they're paying a lot of
money for now
if you get to trade off higher gases
you're putting up with higher price of
hamburgers and gas
versus whether or not you're going to
have to you're going to be able to pay
for uh education and or
child care it's alike i think most
people would make the trade their bottom
line would be better in middle class
households but it's going to be hard and
it's going to take a lot of work
oh sir you mentioned china do you think
the time has come
to begin lifting some of the tariffs on
chinese imports or is there a need for
china to to
make do on some of its commitments in
the phase one agreement some business
groups would like you to begin raising
lifting up those tariffs on well i know
that and that's why my trade rep is
working on that right now the answer is
uncertain
it's uncertain i'd like to be able to be
in a position where i could say they're
meeting the commitments or more of their
commitments and be able to lift some of
it but we're not there yet
um
nancy
cbs
thank you so much mr president this
afternoon the senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell said that the midterm
elections are going to be
a report card on your progress on
inflation border security and standing
up to russia do you think that that's a
fair way to look at it and if so how do
you think that report card looks right
now
i think report cards can look pretty
good if that's where we're at but look
the idea that uh
mitch has been very clear
he's doing anything to prevent biden
from being a success i i get on with
mitch i actually like mitch mcconnell we
like one another but he has one
straightforward objective
make sure that there's nothing i do
that makes me look good
in the mind in his mind with the public
at large and that's okay i'm a big boy
i've been here before
but the fact is that i think that
the
i'm happy to debate
and have a referendum on how i handle
the economy
whether or not i've
made progress on
look again
how can i i'm taking too long answering
your questions i apologize
i think that
this the fundamental question is
what's mitch 4
what's he for
on immigration
what's he for
what's he proposing
to making better
what's he for
dealing with
russia
that's different than i'm proposing that
many of his republican friends or his
colleagues are supporting as well
what's he for
on these things what are they for
so everything's a choice
a choice
i think the look i've laid out a
proposal
on immigration that if we passed it we'd
be in a totally different place right
now but we're not there because we don't
have a single republican vote my buddy
john mccain's gone
so
i mean it's just
it's going to take time
and again i go back to
i go back to
governor sununu's quote
how long i mean a rhetorical question i
don't i know this is not fair to ask the
press the question i'm not asking you
but think about
did you ever think
that one man out of office
could intimidate an entire party
where they're unwilling
to take any vote
contrary to what he thinks should be
taken
for fear of being defeated in the
primary
i've had five
republican senators
talk to me
bump into me quote unquote
or sit with me
who've told me that they agree with
whatever i'm talking about i'm going to
do
but joe
if i do it
i'm going to defeat it in a primary
i got to break that
it's got to change
and i doubt you're all i'm not sounds
like i'm being solicitous you're all
bright as hell well-informed
more informed than any group of people
in america
but did any of you think
that you get to a point
where not a single
republican
would diverge on a major issue
not what
anyway
those five republican senators are sure
no you're kidding me
i uh i i maintain confidentiality
but i'm sure you've spoken to some
on voting rights sir at your first press
conference 10 months ago i asked you if
there was anything you could do beyond
legislation to protect voting rights and
at that time you said yes but i'm not
going to lay out a strategy before you
and the world now
now that legislation appears to be
hopelessly stalled
can you now lay out your strategy to
protect voting rights
well i'm not prepared to do that
in detail in terms of the executive
orders i may be able to engage in and
other things i can do but one of the
things we have done
we have we have significantly beefed up
the number of enforcers in the justice
department
who are there to challenge the these
these unconstitutional efforts in our
view on constituency efforts on the part
of the republicans to stack the election
and subvert the outcomes
we have uh began to organize in ways
that we didn't before
the communities beyond the civil rights
community to make the case to the rest
of the american people what's about to
happen what will happen if in fact these
things move forward
if i had talked to you not you i'm using
you in the ptosis if i've talked to the
public
about
the whole idea of subversion of
elections by deciding who the electors
are after the fact i think people would
have looked at me like whoa i mean i
caught talk constitutional law for 20
years a three credit course and
separation of powers and uh on saturday
morning when i was a senator
and uh i i never thought we'd get into a
place where
um
where we were talking about being able
actually
what they tried to do this last time out
send different electors
to the state legislative bodies to
represent who won the election
saying that i didn't win but republican
candidate won
i doubt with anybody thought that would
ever happen
in america in the 21st century but it's
happening
and so i think i guess what i'm saying
is
nancy is that i think that uh there are
a number of things we can do but i also
think we will be able to get
significant pieces of the legislation if
we don't get it all now
to build to get it so that we get a big
chunk of the john lewis legislation as
well as the fair elections
surround covet if you don't mind you
touted the number of americans who are
now fully vaccinated with two shots but
even some of your own medical advisors
say that people aren't fully protected
unless they have that third shot a
booster why hasn't this white house
changed the definition of fully
vaccinated to include that third booster
shot is it because the numbers of fully
vaccinated americans would suddenly look
a lot less no it's not that at all it's
just this this has been this has become
clear and clear and every time i speak
of it i say
if you've been vaccinated get your
booster shot
everybody get the booster shot it's the
optimum protection you can have
you're protected very well with two
shots if it's the fizer anyway you're
protected
but you are better protected with the
booster shot
the definition right now
i'm following what the
the answer is yes
get the booster shot it's all part of
the same thing you're better protected
um
okay
alex alford reuters
thank you mr president um i wanted to
follow up briefly on a question asked by
bloomberg you said that russia would be
held accountable if it invades and it
depends on what it does it's one thing
if it's a minor incursion and we end up
having to fight about what to do and
what not to do
are you saying that a minor incursion by
russia into ukrainian territory would
not lead to the sanctions that you have
threatened or are you effectively giving
putin permission to make a small
incursion into the country
good question
um
that's how it did sound like didn't it
the most important thing to do
big nations can't bluff
number one
number two
the idea
that we would do anything to split nato
which would be of have a profound impact
on one of
i think probably impact on one of
putin's objectives to weaken nato would
be a big mistake
so the question is
if it's a something significantly short
of
a significant invasion or not even
significant just major military forces
coming across for example
it's one thing to determine that if they
continue
to
to use cyber efforts well we can respond
the same way with cyber
they have fsb people in ukraine now
trying to undermine
the solidarity within ukraine about
russia and to try to promote russian
interest
but it's very important that
that we keep
everyone in nato on the same page
and that's what i'm spending a lot of
time doing and there are differences
there are differences
in nato as to what countries are willing
to do
depending on what happens the degree to
which they're able to go and i want to
be clear with you
the serious imposition of sanctions
relative to dollar transactions and
other things
are things that are going to have a
negative impact on the united states
as well as a negative impact on the
economies of europe as well a
devastating impact on russia
and so i got to make sure everybody's on
the same page
as we move along
i think we will if there's something
that is that where there's russian
forces crossing the border killing
ukrainian fighters etc i think that
changes everything
but it depends on what he does is
actually what extent we're going to be
able to get total unity on the russia on
the
nato front if i may ask a quick one on
iran i just wanted to get your sense of
whether the vienna talks are making any
progress if you still think it's
possible to reach a deal for both sides
to resume compliance with the iran
nuclear deal or if it's time to give up
on that thank you
i'll do it in reverse it's not time to
give up there is some progress being
made
the p5 plus one is on the same page
but it remains to be seen
um
okay
kristin
nbc um very quickly on russia um i do
have a number of domestic policy issues
but on on russia very quickly it seemed
like you said that you have assessed you
feel as though he will move in has this
administration have you determined
whether president putin plans to
invade or move into ukraine as you said
look um
the only thing i'm
confident of
is that decision is totally solely
completely a putin decision
nobody else is going to make that
decision no one else is going to impact
that decision he's making that decision
and
i suspect
it matters
which side of the bed he gets up on in
the morning
as to exactly what he's going to do
and i think it is
not irrational if he wanted to to talk
about
dealing with strategic doctrine and
dealing with
forced structures in europe and in in
the european parts of russia
but
i don't know if he's decided he wants to
do that or not
so far in the three meetings we've had
osce anyway
have have not produced anything because
the impression i get
from my secretary of state my national
security advisor and my other senior
officials that are doing these meetings
is that
there's a question of whether the people
they're talking to know
what he's going to do
so the answer is
but based on
a number of criteria as to what he could
do for example for him to move
in and
occupy the whole country
particularly from the north from belarus
it's uh he's going to have to wait a
little bit until the ground's frozen so
he can cough to move in a direction
where
he wants to talk about what's going we
we have we're continuing to provide
for defense capacities to the
to the ukrainians
we're talking about what's going on
in both the uh the baltic and the black
sea etc there's a whole range of things
that i'm sure
he's trying to calculate how quickly he
can do what he wants to do and what does
he want to do
but i he's not
he's an informed individual
and i'm sure i'm not sure i believe
he's calculating
what the immediate
short term
and the near-term and the long-term
consequences of russia will be
and i don't think he's made up his mind
yet i want to ask you about your
domestic agenda you've gotten a lot of
questions about voting rights
mr president but i want to ask you about
black voters one of your most loyal
constituencies
i was in
congressman clyburn's district yesterday
in south carolina you opened this news
conference talking about him i spoke to
a number of black voters who fought to
get you elected and now they feel as
though you're not fighting hard enough
for them and their priorities and they
told me they see this push on voting
rights more as a last-minute pr push
than it is a legitimate effort to get
legislation passed so what do you say to
these black voters who say that you do
not have their backs as you promised on
the campaign trail i've had their back
i've had their back my entire career
i've never not had their back
and i started on the voting rights
issues long long ago that's what got me
involved in politics in the first place
and
i think part of the problem is
look there's there's significant
disagreement
in every community
on whether or not the timing of
assertions made by
people has been in the most timely way
so i'm sure that there are those who are
saying that why didn't biden
push
john lewis bill
as hard as he pushed at the last month
why didn't he push it six months ago as
hard as he did now
um
the fact is that
there is um
there's a timing
that is not
of one's own choice is somewhat dictated
by events that are happening in country
and around the world as to what the
focus is
but part of the problem is as well
i have not been
out in the community nearly enough
i've been here an awful lot
i find myself in a situation where
i don't get a chance to look people in
the eye
because of both covert and
things that are happening in washington
to be able to go out and do the things
that i've always been able to do pretty
well
connect with people let them take a
measure of my sincerity let them take a
measure of who i am
for example i mean as i pointed out in
south carolina
um you know
last time when i was chairman of
judiciary committee i got the voting
rights act extended for 25 years and i
got strong thurman to vote for it
that's what i've been doing my whole
career
and so the idea that i that
that i didn't either anticipate or
because
i didn't speak to it
as fervently
as they want me to earlier in the
meantime i was spending a lot of time
spent hours and hours and hours
talking with my colleagues on the
democratic side trying to get them to
agree that if in fact
this occurred if this push continued
that they would be there for john lewis
and anyway
so um
but i think that's that's a problem
that i didn't either anticipate or
because
i didn't speak to it
as fervently as they want me to earlier
in the meantime i was spending a lot of
time
spent hours and hours and hours
talking with my colleagues on the
democratic side trying to get them to
agree that if in fact this occurred if
this push continued that they would be
there for john lewis and anyway so um
but i think that's that's a problem
[Music]
that is my own making
by not communicating
as much as i should have yet
you find that
when you deal with members of the black
caucus and others in the united states
congress i still have very close working
relationships so it's like every
community i'm sure that there are
those in the community and
i'm a big labor guy i'm sure there's
people in labor saying why haven't i
been do a b c or d
so it's just going to take a little bit
of time
you put vice president harris in charge
of voting rights are you satisfied with
her work
on this issue and can you guarantee do
you commit that she will be your running
mate in 2024 provided that you run again
yes and yes
okay
expand
find me do you care to expand
no there's no need to i mean i asked the
question she's gonna be my running mate
number one and number two i did put her
in charge i think she's doing a good job
let me ask you
big picture particularly when you think
about voting rights and the struggles
you've had to unify your own party
around voting rights unity was one of
your key campaign promises
in fact in your inaugural address you
said your whole soul was in bringing
america together uniting our people
people heard the speech that you gave on
voting rights in georgia recently in
which you describe those who are opposed
to you to george wallace and jefferson
davis and some people took exception to
that what do you say to those who are
offended by your speech and is this
country more unified than it was when
you first took office
number one
anybody who listened to the speech
i did not say
that they were going to be george
wallace or a bull connor
i said we're going to have a decision in
history
that is going to be marked just like it
was then
you either voted on the side not to make
you george wallace or didn't make you
bull connor but if you did not vote for
the voting rights act back then you were
voting with those who agreed with connor
those who agreed with
with and and so
and i i think mitch did a real good job
of making it sound like i was attacking
them if you notice i haven't attacked
anybody publicly
any senator any any any any congressman
publicly
and my disagreements with them have been
made to them
communicate to them privately or in
person with them
my desire still is look
i underestimated
one very important thing
i never
thought that
the republicans like for example i said
they got very upset i said there are 16
members
of the present united states senate
who voted
to extend the voting rights act
now they got very offended by that i
want an accusation to stating a fact
what has changed
what happened
what happened
why is not a single republican
not one
that's not the republican party so
that's not an attack is the country more
unif is the country more unified than
when you first took office
uh the answer is
based on some of the stuff we've got
done i'd say yes but it's not nearly
unified as it should be look
i still contend
and i know you'll have a right to judge
me by this i still contend
that
unless you can reach consensus in a
democracy
you cannot sustain the democracy
and so this is a real test
whether or not my uh my my uh
my counterpart in china is right or not
when he says autocracies
are the only thing they're gonna prevail
because democracies take too long to
make decisions and countries are too
divided
i believe we're going through one of
those inflection points
in history
that occurs every several generations or
even more than that even more time than
that
where things are changing
almost regardless of any particular
policy
the world's changing
in big ways
we're going to see if you heard me say
this before we're going to see more
change
in the next 10 years we've saw in the
last 50 years
because of technology
because of fundamental alterations in
alliances that are occurring not because
of any one individual just because of
the nature of things
and so i think you're going to see
an awful lot of transition and the
question is can we keep up with it can
we maintain
the democratic institutions that we have
not just here but around the world
to be able to generate democratic
consensus of how to proceed it's going
to be hard
it's going to be hard but it requires it
requires leadership to do it and i'm not
giving up on the prospect of being able
to do that thank you
mr president
thank you sir
there are deep questions
among americans about the competence
of government from the messy rollout of
5g this week to the afghanistan
withdrawal to testing on kovid what have
you done to restore americans faith in
the competence of government and are you
satisfied by the view
of the competence of your government
look
let's take afghanistan i know you all
would like to focus on that which is
legitimate
we were
spending a trillion dollars a week
i mean a billion dollars a week in
afghanistan for 20 years
raise your hand if you think
anyone was going to be able to
unify
afghanistan
under one
single government
it's been the graveyard of empires
for a solid reason
it is not susceptible to unity
number one so
the question was
do i continue
to spend
that much money per week
in the state of afghanistan
knowing that the idea that being able to
succeed
other than sending more body bags back
home is highly highly unusual
my dad used to have an expression
he'd say son if everything's equally
important to you nothing's important to
you
there is no way
to get out of afghanistan after 20 years
easily
not possible no matter when you did it
and i make no apologies for what i did i
have a great concern for the women and
men
who were blown up
on the line at the airport
by a terrorist attack against them
but
the military will acknowledge
and i think you will who know a lot
about foreign policy
that had we stayed
and i had not pulled those troops out
we would be asked to put somewhere
between 20 and 50 000 more troops back
in because the only reason more
americans weren't being killed than
others is because the last president
signed an agreement to get out by may
the first
and so everything was copacetic
had we not got now
and the acknowledgement is we'd be
putting a lot more forces in
now am i do i feel badly
what's happening to
we as a consequence of the incompetence
of the taliban
yes i do but i feel badly also about the
fistulas that are taking place in
eastern congo
i feel badly about a whole range of
things around the world
that we can't solve every problem
and so
i don't view that as a competence issue
the issue of whether or not there's
competence in terms of whether or not
we're dealing with 5g or not
we don't deal with 5g
the fact is that you had two enterprises
two private enterprises
that had one
promoting 5g
and the other one are airlines
they're private enterprises they have
government regulation admittedly
and so what i've done is
pushed as hard as i can
to have
5g folks hold up
and abide by what was being requested by
the airlines until they could more
modernize over the years
so that a 5g would not interfere with
the potential of the landing so any
tower any 5g tower within certain number
of miles from the airport
should not be operative
and that's and so i understand
but anything that happens that's
consequential
is viewed as the government's
responsibility i get that
am i satisfied with the way in which we
have
dealt with uh um covet and all the
things that
that go along with that yeah i am
satisfied i think we've done it
remarkably
well
you know the idea that uh
on testing we've done
we should have done it quicker but we've
done remarkable since then what we have
is we have more testing going on than
anywhere in the world
and we're going to continue to increase
that
did we have it at the moment exactly
when we should have moved and could we
have moved a month earlier yeah we could
have
with everything else that's going on i
don't view that as somehow a mark of
incompetence look think of what we did
on covet
when
uh when we were pushing on
astrazeneca to provide more vaccines
well guess what
they didn't have the machinery to be
able to do it so i physically went
to michigan stood there in a factory
with the head of the
of uh
astrazeneca and said we'll provide the
machinery for you this is what we'll do
we'll help you do it so you can produce
this vaccine more rapidly
i think that's pretty hands-on stuff we
also said right now when people the
hospitalizations are are are overrunning
hospitals and you have docs and nurses
out because of covert they have coveted
we put thousands of people back in in
those hospitals look at all the marine
all the military personnel we have there
first responders
nobody is ever organized nobody is ever
organized
a strategic operation to get as many
shots and arms by opening clinics and
keeping and being able to get so many
people vaccinated what i'm doing now is
not just getting significant amounts of
vaccines to the rest of the world but
they now need the mechanical way is how
they get shots and arms
so we're providing them to know how to
do that
now should everybody in america know
that no i don't necessarily know that
they're just trying to figure out how to
put three squares on the table and stay
safe
but so
i i i do think the the place where
i was a little disappointed i wish we
could have written it differently
is when we did the legislation to
provide the funding for covet and the
money we provided for the states to be
able to deal with keeping schools open
some of them didn't do a very good job
some are still holding the money
i don't have the authority to do
anything about that
i think that's not particularly
competent there's things that could
should have been done they could have
moved faster
so
i uh um
i understand the frustration
you know i remember
uh um
i think it was forget which cabinet
member is saying to barack obama where
something was going on
and he said well you can be sure
mr president of the millions of
employees you have out there somebody's
screwing up right now
somebody's screwing up
so
you know it's just uh but i think you
have to look at things that we used to
look at on balance
what is the trajectory of the country is
it moving in the right direction now
i don't know how we can say it's not i
understand the overwhelming frustration
fear and concern
with regard to inflation
and covet i get it
but the idea if i told you
when we started i'll tell you what i'm
going to do first year i'm going to
create over 600 or 6 million jobs
i'm going to get unemployment down to
3.9 percent i'm going to generate and i
named it all you look at me like you're
nuts maybe i'm wrong
president at least in our recent memory
with as much washington experience as
you entered this office with but yet
after we sit here for more than an hour
i'm not sure i've heard you say if you
would do anything differently in the
second year of your term do you plan to
do anything differently the thing you
have to do satisfied with your team here
at the white house
i'm satisfied with the team there's
three things i'm going to do differently
now that i will now that i've gotten
the critical crises out of the way in
the sense of that movement knowing
exactly where we're going
number one
i'm getting out of this place more often
i'm going to go out and talk to the
public
i'm going to do public fora
i'm going to interface with them i'm
going to make the cases what we've
already done
why it's important and what we'll do if
what will happen if they support what
else i want to do number two
i'm bringing in more and more now that i
have time i mean literally
like you it's i'm not complaining it's
you know 12 14 hours a day no complaints
i really mean that sincerely but now
that certain of the big chunks have been
put in place and we know the direction
i'm also going to be out there seeking
the more advice of experts outside from
academia to editorial writers to think
tanks and i'm bringing them in
just like i did early on bringing in
presidents and historians to get their
perspective on what we should be doing
seeking more input more information
more constructive criticism about what i
should and shouldn't be doing
and the third thing i'm going to be
doing a lot more of is being in a
situation where i'm able to
bring i'm going to be deeply involved
in the off these off year elections
we're going to be raising a lot of money
we're going to be out there making sure
that we're helping all of those
candidates and scores of them already
asked me to come in and campaign with
them to go out and make the case
in plain simple language as to what it
is we've done what we want to do and why
we think it's important
how many more hours am i doing this i'm
happy to stick around
you always ask me the nicest questions
i know you do all right none of them
make a lot of sense to me but i
well let's let's try our way come on new
year uh
why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
well
i'm not
i don't know what you consider to be too
far to the left if in fact we're talking
about
making sure that we had the money for
coven making sure we had the money to
put together the bipartisan
infrastructure making sure we were able
to provide for those things that in fact
would significantly reduce the burden on
working-class people but make them they
have to continue to work hard i don't
know how that is pointed to the left if
you may recall
i you guys have been trying to convince
me that
i am
bernie sanders i'm not i like him but
i'm not bernie sanders i'm not a
socialist
i'm a mainstream democrat and i have
been and mainstream democrats have
overwhelmed if you notice
the
48 of the 50 republic democrats
supported me in the senate on virtually
everything i've asked
yes sir
you were asked whether or not you
believed that we would have free and
fair elections in 2022 if some of the
state legislatures reforms their voting
protocols you said that it depends
do you
do you think that
they would in any way be illegitimate
oh yeah i think it easy could be be
illegitimate imagine
imagine if in fact trump has succeeded
in convincing pence to
not count the votes uh imagine if
in regards to 2022 sir the next 2052 i
mean
imagine if those
attempts to say that
the count was not legit
you have to recount it and we're not
going to count we're going to discard
the following votes i mean sure
it i'm not saying it's going to be legit
it's the increase
in the prospect of being illegitimate is
a direct proportion was not being able
to get these
these reforms passed but i don't think
you're going to see you're not going to
see me and i don't think you're going to
see the democratic party give up on can
go coming back at assuming that the
attempt fails today
one more sir um
you know you talk you campaigned and you
ran on a return to civility and i know
that you dispute the characterization
that you called folks who would oppose
those voting bills um as being bull
connor or george wallace but you said
that they would be sort of in the same
camp no i didn't say that look what i
said go back and read what i said and
tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
so did you expect that that would work
with senators mansion or or cinema
um no here's the thing there's certain
things that are so consequential you
have to speak from your heart as well as
your head
i was speaking out
forcefully on what i think to be at
stake
that's what it is and by the way
no one
no one forgets who was on the side of
king or verse on or bull connor
no one not done that the history books
will note it and when i was making the
case don't think this is a freebie
you don't get to vote this way and then
somehow it goes away this will be stick
with you the rest of your career and
long after you're gone
mr president folks
we've only gone an hour and 20 minutes
i'll keep going but i'm what i'm gonna
go let me get let me get something
straight here
how long are you guys ready to go you
want to go for another hour two
okay
i'm going to go i tell you what folks
uh
i'm going to go another 20 minutes to a
quarter of okay
yes
i'll wait for the sir
um president i want to thank my
communication staff for the great help
here
well uh president biden on the
coronavirus uh we're uh tragically
approaching nearly one million americans
who died
and i'd like to ask you
why it is during your three and a half
hour virtual summit in november with the
chinese president you didn't press for
transparency and also whether that has
anything to do with your son's
involvement in an investment firm
controlled by chinese state-owned
entities
the answer is that we did i did raise
the question of transparency i spent a
lot of time with him
and he uh the fact is that they're just
not they're just not being transparent
transparency on the coronavirus origins
yes
and
you did during a virtual summit is there
a reason your press staff was unaware of
that
and what did you say to the chinese
president and they weren't with me the
entire time look
i
made it clear that i thought that china
had an obligation to be more forthcoming
on exactly what the source of the virus
was and where it came from
yes
mr president i would like to ask you
about foreign policy
one of the first priority
that you declared when you came to
office was to end the war in yemen the
catastrophic war in yemen
you appointed a special envoy today one
of your allies united arab emirates is
asking your administration to put back
the houthi rebels or militias back on
the terror list are you going to do that
and how are you going to end the war in
yemen sir
the answer is
it's under consideration and
ending the war in yemen takes the two
parties to be involved to do it
and uh it's going to be very difficult
yes
thank you very much for this honor james
rosen with newsmax i'd like to um i'd
like to raise a delicate
subject but with utmost respect for your
life accomplishments and the high office
you hold
a
poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49 percent of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
strongly affirmed that statement
well let you all make the judgment
whether they're correct well so the
question i have for you sir if you'd let
me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
yes sir
uh thanks mr president i appreciate it
um i i wanted to sort of address uh or
ask about attention that's been in this
in this press conference on unifying the
country because you campaigned on two
things one of them is being able to
accomplish big things and the other is
the ability to unify the country and
even today you've talked about sort of a
different posture with republicans and i
i wonder if if you still think it's
possible to do both of those things
we have to
we have to i mean
as long as i hold public office i'm
going to continue to attempt to do both
things one more follow-up um
around this time last year when you were
campaigning in georgia i think one of
the things you told people was the power
is literally in your hands you know if
if voters give democrats the house and
the senate and and the presidency that
all these big things can get
accomplished and you know we've seen
stalemate we've seen things being
stymied um
why should folks believe you this time
around can you think of any other
president's done as much in one year
name one for me
i'm asking you
i'm serious
you guys talk about how nothing's
happened
i don't think there's been much
on any incoming presence plate that's
been a bigger menu than the plate i had
given to me i'm not complaining knew
that running in
and the fact of the matter is we got an
awful lot done
an awful lot done
and there's more to get done but look
let's let me ask a rhetorical question
no i won't anyway
thank you
yes
be careful don't get hurt no no i'm i'm
going to take care
mr president thank you sebastian smith
from afp another question on ukraine
uh ukraine borders for nato member
countries
how concerned are you concerned uh that
a real conflagration in ukraine if the
russians really go in there
that it could suck in
nato countries that are on the border
and you end up with an actual
nato-russia confrontation of some kind
and secondly
um
are you entertaining the thought of a
summit with
vladimir putin as a way to perhaps try
and put this whole thing to bed address
their concerns and negotiate a way out
of this the last part the last question
yes when we talked about whether or not
we picked the three meetings we talked
about
and we talked about we would go from
there
if there was reason to to go to a summit
we talked about a summit as being before
the ukraine
item came up in terms of strategic
doctrine and what the strategic
relationship would be
so i still think that is a possibility
number one number two i am very
concerned
i'm very concerned that this could end
up being
look
the only war that's worse than one
that's intended is one that's unintended
and what i'm concerned about
is this could get out of hand
very easily get out of hand because of
what you said the borders of the of
ukraine and what russia may or may not
do
i am hoping that
vladimir putin understands that he is
short of a full-blown nuclear war he's
not a very good position to dominate the
world
and so i don't think he thinks that
but it is a concern
and that's why we have to be very
careful about how we move forward and
make it clear to him that there are
there are prices to pay
that could in fact cost his country an
awful lot
but i of course you have to be concerned
when you have
you know
a nuclear power
invaded this if he invades
it hasn't happened since world war ii
this is the most consequential thing
that's happened
in the world in terms of war and peace
since world war ii
yes
[Music]
uh nearly two years have passed since
the beginning of the global coronavirus
outbreak and you again today acknowledge
that americans are frustrated and
they're tired based on your
conversations with your health advisors
what type of restrictions do you imagine
being on americans this time next year
and what does the new normal look like
for social gatherings and travel to you
well the answer is
i hope the new normal will be that we
don't have still have
30 some million people not vaccinated i
hope the new normal is people have
seen and what their own interest is and
have taken advantage of the of what we
have available to us number two with the
pill that is a problem that appears to
be as
efficacious as it
seems to be
that they're going to be able to deal
with this virus in a way that after the
fact you have an ability to make sure
you don't get yourself you don't get
very sick
number three
i would hope that what happens is the
rest of the world does what i'm doing
and provides significant amounts of the
vaccine to the rest of the world
because it's not sufficient that we just
have this country not have the virus or
be able to control the virus but that
can't build a wall high enough to keep a
new variant out so it requires
one of the things that i want to do and
we're we're contemplating figuring out
how to do not
we are contemplating how to get done and
that is how do we move in a direction
where the world itself
is vaccinated it's not enough
just to vaccinate 340 million fully
vaccinate 340 million people in the
united states
that's not enough
it's not enough to do it we have to do
it and we have to do a lot more than
we're doing now and that's why we have
continued to keep the commitment of
providing vaccines and available
cures for the rest of the world as well
if i could sir and i should have said
this before francesca chambers mcclatchy
how do you plan to win back moderates
and independents who cast a ballot for
you in 2020 but polls indicate aren't
happy with the way you're doing your job
now
i don't believe the polls
well why don't you just go down there
thank you mr president uh follow up on
some of the questions about the
vaccination program we you've given
dozens of speeches this year urging
americans to get vaccinated you've
talked to reluctant republicans you've
said it's people's patriotic duty there
have been very few mentions of the fact
that young children under the age of
five still in the third year of this
pandemic in this country don't have
access to the vaccine can you speak to
frustrated parents a little bit about
why that continues to be the case and
when that might change because the
science hasn't reached the point where
they convinced that in fact it is safe
so that's what they're doing now you
could have asked me that i got asked
that question about three months ago
about people between the ages of you
know seven and twelve well it finally
they got to the point where they felt
secure in the number of tests they had
done and the test had run that it was
safe so it will come it will come but i
can't i'm not a scientist i can't tell
you when but it is really very important
that we get down to that next piece
one more follow-up on buildback better
when you said it's going to likely be
broken up into chunks you mentioned that
the climate pieces seem to have broad
support you mentioned that senator
manchin is a as a supporter of
early child care you left out the child
tax credit and i wonder if it's fair to
read between the lines and assume that
that is a piece given senator manchin's
opposition to it uh that the extension
of that is likely one of those
components that may have to wait uh
until sometime
really big components that i feel
strongly about that i'm not sure i can
get in the package
one is the child care tax credit
and the other is
help for
cost of community colleges
they are massive things that i've run on
i care a great deal about i'm going to
keep coming back at whatever four i get
to be able to try to get chunks or all
of that done
yes sir next man next to you left
thank you mr president my name is pero
rojas abbot univision national news
ah this is actually my first press
conference here as a good to meet you in
person we always have long press
conferences awesome
awesome
i got a couple of questions for you
number one uh you said that you want to
convey your message by getting out there
in the country i wonder if you're
planning on traveling also to south
america and other countries in the in
the western hemisphere
given the fact that china has has gained
a lot of influence in the region
and the second question is
what will be your message for residents
in this country that are struggling
every time they go to the gas station
every time they go to the grocery store
and see the prices going high
and the pharmacy i happen to come from
south texas where i saw a lot of a lot
of people struggling financially in the
last few months
and so i think you
i wonder what is the message you want to
spread to them
well i try to express i've asked i tried
to answer that seven different ways
today about how to deal with inflation
but let me answer the first question
i spent a lot of time in south america
and in latin america when i was vice
president i spent the bulk of my years
basically in europe and or in
latin america i'm in contact with the
leaders of the countries in south
america we're working closely
with making sure that we do everything
for example
with the uh to deal with
helping
the countries in question particularly
those in central america to be able to
help them with their ability to deal
with
the inter
people don't sit around in
guatemalans i got a great idea let's
sell everything we have give the money
to a to a
a coyote take us across a terribly
dangerous trip up through central
america and up through mexico and drop
us sneakers across the border drop us in
the desert won't that be fun
people leave because they have real
problems and one of the things i've done
when i was a vice president got support
with although i don't have much
republican support anymore is provide
billions of dollars to be able to say to
those countries
why are people leaving and how are you
going to reform your own system
and that's we've worked on a long time
it still needs a lot more work and we're
focusing on that i also
believe i've spent a lot of time talking
about and dealing with policy having to
do with maduro who is a little more than
a dictator right now
and the same thing in chile and
uh and not the same thing but with chile
as well as argentina so look i've i made
a speech a while ago when i was vice
president
saying that
if we were smart
we have an opportunity to make the
western hemisphere
a
united not united a democratic
hemisphere
and we were moving in the right
direction
under our
last administration the obama biden
administration
but so much damage was done as a
consequence of the foreign policy
decisions the last president made
in
latin america central america and south
america
that
we now have when i call for a summit of
the democracies
i call that and a number of nations
showed up for this summit of democracy
what is it that's going to allow us
to generate we've actually had a
reduction in the number of democracies
in the world
and it seems to me there's nothing more
important we used to talk about
when i was a kid in college about
america's backyard it's not america's
backyard
said everything south of the mexican
border is america's front yard
and we're equal people we don't dictate
what happens in any other part of that
of this continent or the south american
continent we have to work very hard on
it but the trouble is we're having great
difficulty making up for the mistakes
that we made the last four years and
it's going to take some time
yes gentlemen on the back and then i'll
go to this side okay
thank you mr president alexander
nazarian yahoo news um and thank you for
holding this press conference i hope
there's more of them um
any time you have extra three hours we
can do it
we'll stay for a couple more um
you said you were surprised by
republican obstruction of your agenda
but didn't the gop take exactly the same
tactic
when you were vice president to barack
obama so
why did you think they would treat you
any differently than they treated him
first of all they weren't nearly as
obstructionist as they are now
number one
they stated that but you had a number of
republicans we work with closely from
john mccain i mean a number of
republicans we worked closely with
even back in those days lindsey graham
and so
the difference here is
there seems to be a desire to work with
and i didn't say my agenda i'm saying
what are they for what what is their
agenda
they had an agenda
back in the administration
when the eight years we were president
vice president but i don't know what
their agenda is now
what is it
the american public is outraged about
the tax structure we have in america
what are they proposing to do about it
anything
have you heard anything i mean anything
i haven't heard anything
the american public is outraged about
the fact that we're
the uh the the the state of the
environment the vast majority of the
public what have they done to do
anything to ameliorate the climate
change that's occurring other than to
deny it exist so what i'm saying is the
difference between then and now is not
only the announcement that was made
anything to stop barack obama i get that
part
but what eventually happened
we were able to get some things done we
were able to work through some things on
the stuff that was really consequential
in terms of ideologically divisive it
was a real fight
but so
but i don't think there's a time when i
i mean i wonder what would be the
republican platform right now
what do you think what do you think your
position on taxes though
what do you think their position on on
human rights
i think their position is on
whether or not uh
uh we should uh on what we should do
about the cost of prescription drugs
what do you think i mean i i just i
honestly god don't know what they're for
yet i know a lot of these senators and
congressmen and i know they do have
things they want to support
whether there's things i want or not
but you don't hear much about that
and every once in a while when you hear
something where there's a consensus
it's important but a small item and it
doesn't get much coverage at all
where it occurs i'm not mean coverage i
mean there's not much discussion about
it
so i just think it's a different and i i
don't know
that um
no matter how strongly
one supports as a republican and or
supports
the president of the former president
united states i don't know how we can't
look at
what happened on
january 6th and think that's
that's a problem
that's a real problem
one one more question mr president um by
the way it's a quarter of guys now so
i'm going to do this just let's if you
ask me easy questions i'll give you
quick answers oh there's an increasing
concern i think among some democrats
that
even if schools do continue to open and
i get that most of them are now open
republicans will
weaponize this narrative of you
of you and other leading democrats
allowing them to stay closed in the
midterms next year
and you know obviously that issue has a
lot of traction with
suburban parents um as i think we're
saying
i'm confused by the question i'm sorry
well that could school
reopenings or closures become a potent
midterm issue for republicans to win
back the suburbs
oh i think it could be but i hope in god
that they're
that
look
maybe i'm kidding myself
but as time goes on
the voter
who
is just trying to figure out as i said
how to take care of their family put
three squares on the table stay safe be
able to pay their mortgage or their rent
etc
has is becoming
much more informed on
the um
the motives of
some of the political
players
and some of the uh
and the political parties
and i think that
they are not going to be as susceptible
to believing
some of the outlandish things that have
been said
and continue to be said
you know every
every president not necessarily in the
first 12 months but every president
first couple years
most every president excuse me the last
president at least four of them
have had
polling numbers that are 44
favorable so it's this idea that but you
all not you all but now it is well
biden's it
one poll showed him at 33
the average is 44
forty five percent one poem at 49
i mean
the idea that um
the american public are trying to
sift their way through
what's real and what's and what's fake
and i don't think
as uh
i've never seen a time
when
the political coverage the
choice of what political coverage the
voter looks to
has as much impact on what they believe
they go to get reinforced
in their views
whether it's
msnbc or whether it's fox or whatever i
mean
and one of the things i find fascinating
that's happening and you all are dealing
with it every day and it will impact on
on how things move
is that
a lot of the speculation and the polling
data shows
that
the um
[Music]
that the uh cables are
heading
south
they're losing viewership
you know
well
fox is okay for a while but it's not
gaining and a lot of the rest are
predicted to be
not very much in the in the mix
in the next four to five years i don't
know if that's true or not
but i do know
that we have sort of uh
put everybody in put themselves in
certain alleys
and they've decided that
you know
how many people
who watch msnbc also watch fox other
politicians trying to find out what's
going on in both places
how many people
again i'm no expert in any of this but
the fact is
i think you have to acknowledge that
what gets covered now
is
necessarily a little bit different
than what gets covered in the past
i've had a couple
washington
but the nature
not
the nature of the way
things get covered
as in my observation over the years i've
been involved in public life changed
and it's changed because of everything
from a thing called the internet
has changed because of the way in which
we have self-identified
perspectives based on what channel you
turn on
what what what network you look at that
network what cable you look at
and it's um it's never quite been like
that
anyway
on on behalf of the correspondents
association thank you very much for
for standing for our questions we hope
the public has found it as enlightening
as those of us in the room have i want
to ask you sarah about one of the
overviews you still stand right
we appreciate it we
we very much do so uh the question i
want to ask you guys to accountability
sir uh on one of the top public concerns
of course which is the coronavirus and
the government's response to it whether
it's
confusion over what style of mask to
wear
when to test how to test where to test
you know the the public is confused sir
and you see that in in the drop-off in
the polling on this question
why did you tell jeff that you were
satisfied with your team
why are you not willing to make or
interested in making any changes uh
either at the cdc or other agencies
given the fact that the messages have
been so confusing well first of all
the message is to the extent they've
been confusing is because the scientists
they're learning more
they're learning more about what's
needed and what's not needed
and so
the fact is that the one piece that has
got a lot of attention is the
the uh
the communications capacity of the cdc
well she came along and said look i'm
not
i mean i'm a scientist
and i'm learning
i'm learning how to deal with
stating what is the case that we've
observed
um
but look i think that it's a little bit
like saying
when we went through the whole issue of
how to deal with polio and the polio
shots
what was said in the beginning
was oh no it's changed a little bit we
moved this way that way or when we dealt
with anything else i mean
uh
as
this was a brand new
virus
a brand new phenomenon
some of it was deadly
otherwise more communicable
this is this is an unfolding story
it's the nature of the way diseases
spread we're going to learn about it in
a lot of other areas the distance not
just covet 19
and so
i think you know i look at it this way
think about
how astounding it was within the time
frame that it took
to be able to come up with a vaccine
you used to write about that
pretty amazing
how rapidly they came up with a vaccine
that saved hundreds of thousands of
lives
did everything get right no
and by the way the idea whether we
anyway i'm
talking too much thank you mr president
i have two really simple questions
i promise
you campaigned on canceling ten thousand
dollars in student loans do you still
plan to do so and when and then my
second question is now that you've
clarified the bull connor comments do
you plan to reach out to republicans
like mitt romney to talk about reforming
the electoral count act yes i'm happy to
speak out i've i've met with rip i've
talked to mitt on other occasions and by
the way i reached out to the the
minority the minority leader as well
at the time this that he they made a
speech
and so
um
[Music]
i have no reluctance
to reach out to any republican
and anyone who and i've made it clear
look i've now had the opportunity to
travel
because of
funerals and eulogies i've made and
attended and congressmen and senators
have come along with me
i don't don't hold me to the number but
somewhere
between 20 and 25 senators and
congresspersons have traveled with me
and i find you should get the list of
them and ask what how we i you know set
for the two three four five hours that
we've flown together sit back in the in
that conference table talk to them ask
them questions they ask me questions i
learn a heck of a lot but as president
you don't quite have that ability to do
that as often as i'd like to be able to
do it
and one of the things that i do think
that has been made clear to me speaking
of polling
is the public doesn't want me to be the
president senator
they want me to be the president and let
senators be senators
and so
if i've made i've made many mistakes i'm
sure if i've made a mistake i'm used to
negotiating to get things done and i've
been
in the past relatively successful at it
in the united states senate even as vice
president but i think that role as
president
is
is a different role folks
it is now
almost six
with all due respect i'm gonna see you
next conference okay thank you
thank you mr president
you